[Applaus]
[Musik]
frag doch mal auf dem Globus mit dem
Finger den 50 Breitengrad ostwärts
sozusagen entgegen der Strömungsrichtung
des gegenwärtigen nachrichtenflusses von
Frankfurt am Main kommt ihr da über Prag
und Krakau direkt nach Kiew und aufgrund
der russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
momentan die reinsten epizzentren des
Weltgeschehens
weiter ostwärts folgen dann gerade mal
650 Kilometer Russland ebenfalls ein
newsmaker erster Güte zumeist aber mit
negativen Vorzeichen doch dahinter
beginnt ein Land von dem wir kaum etwas
hören was ich aber gleich über gewaltige
3000 Kilometer weiter nach Osten
erstreckt Kasachstan mal zugegeben viele
wissen über Kasachstan nur dass es die
angebliche Heimat der Kino Knallcharge
Borat ist ihr erinnert euch diese
investigative Reporter im knallgelbenden
ist doch tatsächlich gelangt die gewinnt
Essenz der uramerikanischen
konservativen Volksseele zu enthüllen um
Borat geht's heute aber leider nicht
sondern darum wie sich das flächenmäßig
riesige Land Kasachstan jetzt
positioniert nachdem durch Putins
Ukraine kriegt das politische Gefüge im
Post sowjetischen Raum gewaltig aus den
Fugen geraten ist und wir werden uns
ansehen wie dies auch uns hier im besten
tankiert denn kasachstan ist ein
bedeutender Produzent viele
Energierohstoffe unter anderem Erdöl
Erdgas und Uran also hier in den
Rohstoffen nach denen sich die ganze
Welt gegenwärtig die Finger leckt
zumindest wenn sie zu einem akzeptablen
Preis zu haben sind aber kasachstan hat
da ein Problem und dieses Problem heißt
mal wieder Russland da sind wir wieder
auf unserer Reiseroute auf den 50
Breitengrad um uns in der Gegenrichtung
sein Öl liefern zu können muss
Kasachstan es durch Russland leiten nun
ihr ahnt dass da etwas in letzter Zeit
hageln könnte gut aber der Reihe nach
fangen wir mit zwei hard facts an
kasachstan ist eine klassische
extrovertische Diktatur unterdrückte
Opposition Wahlen ohne echte Demokratie
lausige Pressefreiheit und so weiter das
Land wird beherrscht von Clans und
Seilschaften welche die Einnahmequellen
des Landes unter sich aufgeteilt haben
Check und auch wenn üblicherweise wenig
Nachrichten aus Kasachstan zu uns
durchdringen ihr könnt euch sicherlich
daran erinnern dass Anfang dieses Jahres
im Januar 2022 Wladimir Flugzeug eine
schnelle Eingreiftruppe nach Kasachstan
schickte es das Regime zu retten nachdem
bei gewaltsamen Protesten die Lage in
mehreren Städten außer Kontrolle geraten
war wir haben damals sogar ein Video
darüber gedreht dass ich euch verlinken
werde so das ist sozusagen die
Ausgangslage für unser heutiges Video
auf den ersten Blick scheint Kasachstan
also ein Vasallenstaat ein absolut Kreml
treues Land zu sein nicht wahr doch als
Anfang März in der UNO Vollversammlung
der russische Einmarsch in die Ukraine
diskutiert wurde gab es eine
Überraschung
[Musik]
neben Russland steht nur vier andere
Länder gegen die Verurteilung der
Invasion zu den Putin treuen Ländern
gehörten damals Belarus und der
Lukaschenka Nordkorea unter Kim Jong-un
Syrien Unterbacher la sad und Eritrea
unter einer tyrannischen Knallcharge der
Name mir jetzt entfallen ist kurz gesagt
das feinste vom Feinsten aus dem Lager
der Antidemokraten aber keine Spur von
Kasachstan dass sich unter seine
Präsidenten Cassin schon mal türkeiew
der Stimme enthalten hatte ja ich weiß
schon was viele von euch jetzt denken
mag mach mal halblang wen kümmern in der
realen Weltpolitik schon UN-Resolution
Papier ist ja bekanntlich geduldig da
ist leider sehr viel dran aber im Juni
sagte Präsident Türkei 11 auf einem
Wirtschaftsforum in St Petersburg
folgendes sogar im Gegenwart Potenz
wir erkennen wie da Taiwan noch den
Kosovo noch südostsee ziehen und ab
Asien an und so wie es aussieht wird
dieses Prinzip auch auf quasi staatliche
Gebilde angewandt zu denen unserer mein
doch auch nur Hans und Don jetzt gehört
ihr könnt euch sicher vorstellen für den
Camel und putin war das ein affron
geradezu Eintritt in den Allerwertesten
durch den einzigen bedeutenden
ausländischen Staatschef der überhaupt
zu Putins Wirtschaftsforum gekommen war
aber Kasachstan tut sich wahrlich nicht
leicht mit solchen Aussagen denn egal
wie viel Gas und Öl kasachstan hat egal
wie sehr es schon dass du bei der
eurasischen Steppe ist seine Wirtschaft
ist traditionell sehr intensiv mit der
russischen verflochten
in der Tat fließt das gesamte an die
Europäische Union gelieferte kasachische
Öl durch russisches Gebiet denn ein 6%
des von den 27 EU-Staaten importierten
Öls kommen aus Kasachstan es stellt sich
also die Frage warum Kasachstan denn
noch Russland politisch in den Rücken
fällt und wie sich das auf Europa
auswirken könnte heute werden wir
natürlich all diese Fragen beantworten
bevor wir jedoch zur Touch reiten möchte
ich euch ein neues Spiel unseres
Sponsors goldgeldes vorstellen dass mehr
als Gamer recht positiv aufgefallen ist
denn es kommt nicht nur mit perfekter
Grafik nachher erstmal sticht unter den
vielen Online Fantasy-Rollenspiel mit
einer sehr interessanten Idee heraus der
Name bloodline hero of leasers denn über
die ganzen Genre üblichen Elemente
hinaus wie das Sammeln und Trainieren
von Helden mit denen du dann in den
Kampf triffst steht im Zentrum seines
Gameplays eine sehr originelle und
aufrecht interessante Weise umgesetzte
Spielmechanik ein paarungs- und
vererbungssystem ja du hast richtig
gehört du kannst die verschiedenen
bloodlin Blutlinien wie Orks likaner
Dämonen oder Dragonballs miteinander
schnapseln lassen ihre süßen Babys erben
dann die Kombination der Eigenschaften
der Eltern und je besser die Partner
zueinander passen desto stärkere Champs
zeugen sie für dich daraus kannst du dir
dann über viele Generationen riesige
familienbäume heranzüchten bist du die
für deine Herrscher Dynastie optimalen
fähigkeitskombinationen gefunden hast
mit deren Hilfe brauchst du dann
mächtige Königreiche sogar mit eigener
Wirtschaft auf es entsteht eine
unendlich große Zahl an Möglichkeiten
als Blutlinie entstehen zum Beispiel die
Lykaner zur Verfügung keinen Plan von
Werwolf assassins die Kalk Dragon Balls
die sich in einen Drachen verwandeln
können und die fulkur mächtige
Halbgötter mit area of effect
Fähigkeiten so und wenn du dich über
unseren Aktionslink anmeldest erhältst
du die Dragonball als kostenlose
bloodline plus exklusiv einen Erben der
eine Kreuzung aus Dragon Ball und
Halbgöttern darstellt was im Spiel eine
extrem seltene und wertvolle Combo ist
Plus in dem Währung im Wert von 30 die
dir ein optimalen Staatssicherheit in
ganze 200 Diamanten zwei summoning
Kristalle und 5 ausdauertränke zögert
also keine Sekunde den bloodlines ist
gerade jetzt am 21 September mit seinen
europäischen Servern gestartet ihr
werdet also die ersten sein die mit den
Aufbau mächtiger familienbäume und
Königreich anfangen können Ihr seht es
lohnt sich wirklich dieses innovative
free-to-play RPG mal anzuspielen das
Spiel enthält zwar später leichte
pay-to-progress Elemente aber es handelt
sich nicht um ein pay to win Game man
kann auch ohne echtes Geld vorankommen
und viel Spaß haben also klickt jetzt
gleich auf den Link in der Beschreibung
oder nutzt unseren QR-Code den wir euch
eingeblendet haben um euer exklusives
visualpolitik Starter Pack nicht zu
verpassen vergesst bitte auch nicht dass
ihr mit euren Klick auch uns finanziell
unter die Arme greift und es kostet euch
wie gesagt nichts unterstützen könnt ihr
uns natürlich auch mit Hilfe des PayPal
Spenden links den ich euch ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Art der Unterstützung
dankbar denn damit hält ihr uns euch in
Zukunft noch mehr noch bessere Videos zu
liefern zum Beispiel schon sehr bald auf
dem neuen Kanal visual economic
Deutschland aber so und jetzt schnell
nach Kasachstan wo wir in guter alter
visualpolitik Tradition zunächst einen
Blick in die Geschichte werfen werden
[Musik]
der Fallout der Sowjetunion
wenn es ein Land gibt das unter den
Folgen seiner Zugehörigkeit zur
Sowjetunion richtig heftig gelitten hat
dann ist es Kasachstan wir auf
visualpolitik vertreten den Standpunkt
dass die UdSSR ein waschechtes
Kolonialreich war und die Armen Kasachen
haben mehr als nur ein bisschen gelitten
ich erkläre es an einem Beispiel der
Atombombe wir alle wissen dass die
Atombombe eine barbarische Waffe ist
aber was hältst Du davon Atomwaffen an
den eigenen Bürgern zu testen
nun sehr aufmerksame
visualpolitikzuschauer werden sich
vielleicht an unser spannendes Video
über biologische Waffen erinnern damals
haben wir unter anderem darüber
berichtet wie zum Beispiel die USA
geheime Tests an ihrer eigenen
Bevölkerung durchgeführt haben für alle
die es noch nicht gesehen haben werde
ich es oben hinter dem i und in der
Beschreibung verlinken nun den Kasachen
ist noch etwas viel schlimmeres wieder
erfahren nur halt mit Atomwaffen die
meisten Opfer lebten dabei in der Stadt
Kutscher top wo sich das wichtigste
sowjetische Atomtestgelände Semit
Paladin befand sogar die Menschen ins
150 km Entfernung statt waren davon
betroffen Geheimdienstchef berias talins
bedingungsloses der Unterstützer und
rücksichtsloserster schlechter bietet
dieses Gebiet aus und die Auswirkungen
der Strahlung auf den menschlichen
Körper zu untersuchen und aus diesem
Grund führten dies vorwärts
atombombenfest in direkter Nähe
bewohnter Siedlungen durch die
wesentlichen Forschungsarbeiten auf
diesem Gebiet wurden in Kasachstan
durchgeführt es ist einer der wenigen
Orte auf der Welt an dem Menschen zu
Forschungszwecken realer Strahlung bei
kein Waffentest ausgesetzt waren so weit
so grausam es versteht sich aber von
selbst das nicht alles sowjetischen
Einflüsse so fatal waren in Kasachstan
befindet sich zum Beispiel das berühmte
Kosmodrom bei Condor tatsächlich pachtet
der Kreml diesen Weltraumbahnhof bis
heute für viel Geld von der Regierung
Kasachstans
Kasachstan russland will bei Condor bis
mindestens 2050 weiter nutzen und wenn
ihr euch jetzt fragt gut abgesehen von
Atombomben und weltraumraketen was haben
die Sowjets den Kasachen denn noch alles
gebracht nun ganz zu Anfang machte die
Sowjetunion die Kasachen eigentlich
einen Nomadenvolk zu Bauern ihrer neuen
kollektivbetriebe und das Resultat war
katastrophal Hungersnöte forderten in
den 1930er Jahren das Leben von 1,5
Millionen Kasachen sage und schreibe ein
Viertel der Bevölkerung von
erbarmungslos ausgerottet ja genau
Stalin wütete mit seinem genozidahlen
hungerterrorde als holodor Mord bekannt
ist nicht nur in der Ukraine sondern
auch im Kasachstan dem Kreml kam
Völkermord geradezu gelegen denn er
wusste genau wie er das Land wieder nach
seinem Gusto bevölkern konnte natürlich
so zynisch und menschenverachtend wie
nur möglich Säuberungen in Form von
massenhafter Vertreibung waren in der
Sowjetunion an der Tagesordnung
Kasachstan wahrnehmen Sibirien eines der
Hauptziel für die Verbannung von
Millionen von Bürgern die das soweit
macht lästig waren darunter auch
Hunderttausende von Russlanddeutschen
vor allem aus dem wolga-gebiet viele von
ihnen landeten auch in den dortigen
Zwangsarbeitslagern wurden noch
jahrzehntelang diskriminiert der
überwiegende Teil dieser nach Kasachstan
Deportierten Russlanddeutschen wanderte
dann nach dem Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs
nach Deutschland aus und bildet den
größten Teil der sogenannten
spätaufsiedler darüber hinaus druckt die
zwangs- und Siedlung vorne Russen auch
zur rossifizierung Kasachstans bei
poetischer Russen mehr als ein halbes
Jahrhundert lang bis zu den Jahren von
Michael Gorbatschow die Mehrheit
bildeten auch hier war die zynische
Logik des Sowjet Imperiums dessen
Untergang Wladimir Putin als das größte
geopolitische Unglück 20 Jahrhunderts
bezeichnete dasselbe wie die eines jeden
brutalen Kolonialreichs für Moskau war
Kasachstan nichts als eine riesiges
Brachland in dem es seine größten
wahnsinnigen landwirtschaftlichen Pläne
umsetzen konnte bei denen die weiten
beide Flächen in eine Kornkammer für die
Sowjetunion verwandelt werden sollten in
diesem Gebieten siedelte man zu diesem
Zweck jede Menge russische Bevölkerung
an auch um die politischen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Eliten der
kasachischen Sowjetrepublik zu
monopolisieren und auch heute noch ist
Russisch neben dem kasachischen
Amtssprache im Land
[Musik]
das erklärt auch warum die Kasachen ihre
ehemaligen Kolonisatoren nicht besonders
mögen und in der Tat gibt es Anzeichen
für eine entrusifizierung die Kasachen
kehren zum lateinischen Alphabet zurück
und geben das kyrillische Alphabet bis
2023 auf gut ihr meint das wären
kinderlätzchen alles nur reines
Symbolpolitik nicht so voreilig denn das
ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs anhören
und die Maus die alles russische bei den
Kasachen hervorruft und manche von euch
mögen vielleicht denken das wäre nicht
weiter schlimm wenn sie sich so benehmen
auch für die Unabhängigkeit Kasachstans
schon mehr als 30 Jahre zurückliegt aber
es gibt da zwei Details die wir nicht
aus den Augen verlieren sollten
erstens von 1990 an Bahn dort nur Sultan
der macht also schon bevor Kasachstan
überhaupt von der Sowjetunion unabhängig
wurde ja genau der kommunistische
Statthalter regierte nach der Wende
einfach munter weiter es ist daher nicht
verwunderlich das für den 10 Wandel kein
geringerer als präsidentmesser bei
selbstverantwortlich ist dessen Name
seit 2019 übrigens der offizielle Name
der Hauptstadt ist ja genau nur Sultan
die mit allem des Guten Punkt in die
Steppe gesetzte Hauptstadt ist bis 2019
Astana vor 1998 akamola und noch davor
in der Sowjet Zeit sellino Grad ihr
dürft also schon mal raten welchen Namen
sie in Zukunft tragen wird und in
wenigen Minuten verraten wir es euch
eine entscheidende Veränderung
untereinander dabei war allerdings die
Öffnung des Landes für ausländische
Investoren um die enormen natürlichen
Ressourcen Kasachstans auszubeuten und
dazu gehören auch große Öl und Gasfelder
das zweite Detail das ist zu beachten
gilt die kasachische Wirtschaft war eng
mit der technischen verflochten so dass
in gewisser Weise dazu verdammt waren
miteinander auszukommen wenn Russland
niest bekommen wir eine Erkältung
kasachisches Sprichwort und von diesem
Hintergrund benehmen sich die Kasachen
eben an manchen Tagen pro russisch oder
manchen anderen nicht natürlich hat
Russland immer alles getan um sie in
seinem Einflussbereich zu halten nehmen
wir zum Beispiel die eurasische
Wirtschaftsunion eine Organisation die
von Putin propagiert wurde um den
russischen Einfluss auf den Gebiet der
extrovert Union und damit auch ein
Zentralasien zu stärken und um zugleich
zu verhindern dass ich die Region zu
sehr nach China orientiert denn auch
unserer zu Anfang dieses Videos
angetretenen Reise nach Osten mit dem
Finger auf der Landkarte erinnert euch
käme das mächtige Reich der Mitte gleich
hinter Kasachstan als die eurasische
Union 2014 ins Leben gerufen wurde hat
der Kasachstan guten Grund vorsichtig zu
sein und eine zu enge politische
Verpflichtung abzulehnen denn ein
Viertel seiner Bevölkerung ist große
stämmig ganz im Norden des Landesstellen
Russen nach wie vor die ethnische
Mehrheit und ihr erinnert euch Putin
2014 einen ähnlichen Vorwand benutzt um
die grin zu annektieren deshalb haben
die Kasachen immer wieder versucht ihre
Autonomie und Souveränität zu betonen
und nicht in allen Belangen von Russland
abhängig zu sein doch dann kamen die
Aufstände im Januar 2022 und Türkei
jetzt seit 2019 Präsident Kasachstans
ist geriet in eine Zwickmühle der
kasachische Präsident bitte den von
Russland geführten sicherheitsblog um
Hilfe natürlich stellte diese
Intervention eine gute Gelegenheit für
Russland da sich kräftig in die
Angelegenheiten Kasachstans einzumischen
formell geschah dies im Rahmen der ovks
eines seit 2002 bestehenden
Militärbündnis zahlreicher
explodiertischer Staaten sicher hat
Präsident Türkei damals auch in andere
Richtungen nach Hilfe Ausschau gehalten
doch weder die USA noch die EU wollten
sich für den Diktator in die Bresche
werfen zu präsent wäre militärische
Hilfe für einen Tyrann also hatte er
keine andere Wahl als seinen Joker Putin
einzusetzen aber zu welchem Preis zum
Preis der absoluten Realität könnte man
meinen doch schaut es euch besser an
auch du mein Sohn Brutus
nach der blitzintervention russischer
Truppen die Türkei jetzt an der Macht
hielten schien es dass die Beziehungen
zwischen Kasachstan und Russland enger
sind denn je doch keine zwei Monate
später griff Putin die Ukraine an und
weil er schon seit Jahren in
Zentralasien am Aufbau eines regionalen
Blocks unter russischer Führung arbeitet
erwartet er vermutlich dass all diese
Länder ihn unterstützen die dortigen
fünf Stars fühlten sich jedoch zum Thema
Ukraine Krieg in vielsagendes Jahr
ohrenbetäubendes schweigen und nicht nur
das Putin musste schon im Januar erleben
dass er eben erst gerettete Türkei jetzt
in offenbar aus dem Ruder lief schaut
einfach mal was sogar die russische
Presse damals schrieb was für ein
Rückschlag das Netz empört sich über die
Ernennung eines russophoben zum
Informationsminister in Kasachstan
[Musik]
der Kurs den Türkei jetzt nach dem
Eingreifen der russischen Truppen
eingeschlagen hat zeigt dass der
kasachische Präsident Putin nicht über
den Weg traut oder vielmehr das auf gar
keinen Fall als Marionette Moskaus
gesehen werden will und deshalb hat
Tokai jetzt so bald er wieder glaubte
sicher auf dem Tod zu sitzen durch
zahlreiche Gesten unterstrichen dass er
dem russischen Einfluss ganz klaren
Einhalt gebieten wird zudem macht er
auch mit allem Schluss was nach dem
früheren Präsidenten nasser baje war
auch warum nun zum einen um sein eigenes
unabhängiges Image zu befestigen und zum
anderen weil es die ottourage des
ehemaligen Präsidenten war die die
meisten Verbindungen zum Kreml hatte
zumindest ist das jetzt das Bild dass du
kein vermitteln willst deshalb hat er
sobald er konnte seinen Vorgänger zum
Sündenbock gemacht er kassierte die
Ämter und Würden den es dabei jetzt noch
Inhalte allesamt ein wie zum Beispiel
den Vorsitz des Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats er feuerte auch dessen
Tochter der riganasarayeva die 2019
Präsidentin des Senats geworden war
inzwischen sitzt sie nicht einmal mehr
im Parlament aber Türkei hat es nicht
dabei belassen
Kasachstan wichtige dass dabei vertraute
werden offenbar geschafft Neffe des
ehemaligen Präsidenten als
stellvertretender Leiter des mächtigen
Sicherheitsdienstes entlassen und prompt
ganz frisch aber nicht wirklich
überrascht diese Meldung
und benennt Hauptstadt um Präsident
türkeijew unterzeichnete ein Gesetz mit
den der Name der Hauptstadt von nur
Sultan in Astana geändert wird und viele
von euch fragen sich vielleicht warum
überhaupt das alles nun berichten
zufolge glaubt Türkei dass die schweren
Unruhen im Januar durch den Ex
Präsidenten der Salbe nahestehende Kreis
angezeigt wurden dem Ziel dass die
kasachische Regierung dem Kreml Tür und
Tor ins Land öffnet sie waren also eine
falls Flat Aktion Potenz und ja Türkei
ist darauf reingefallen und hast damals
Putin die Schlüssel zu Kasachstan
gegeben aber sobald die russischen
Truppen wieder abgezogen waren tauschte
als erstes das Schloss aus
Türkei jetzt legt sich allerdings nicht
mit dem Kreml an weil er ein Freund der
Demokratie wäre sondern wegen der Frage
des Souveränität am Beispiel der Ukraine
sieht er wozu Russland in der Lage ist
wenn es um eine ehemalige Sowjet
Republik geht und eine russische
Invasion würde nicht nur das kasachische
Volk bedrohen sein auch Türkei jetzt
macht gefährden am Beispiel Weißrussland
sieht er das Unterstützung für Russland
im Kreml einen Freibrief zum Missbrauch
der kasachischen Souveränität geben
würde denn wenn Putin auf den Tisch haut
muss lukaschenker Spuren und kein
Staatschef der etwas auf sich hält will
vollkommen zu Marionette eines anderen
werden der schlaue kasachische Präsident
ist sich aber auch dessen bewusst dass
er beim besten punkten kann wenn er
Russland nicht unterstützt und die
Unterstützung des Westens könnte Türkei
jetzt sehr gelegen kommen um den alten
kasachischen Eliten die immer noch von
dabei kontrolliert werden weiter das
Wasser abzugraben das Problem für
Kasachstan ist natürlich das Putin nicht
tatenlos zusehen wird während sie ihn
herausfordern Russland schließt
nach dem Kasachstan angeboten hat mehr
Öl in die EU zu liefern über den
russischen
exportiert Kasachstan 80% seines Öls
[Musik]
das Kaspische dass diese 1500 Kilometer
lange Pipeline von dem kasachischen
Ölfeldern zum Schwarzen Meer verwaltet
hat es jedoch geschafft dass dort die
get Terminal im Juli wieder in Betrieb
zu nehmen trotzdem wird diese Pipeline
immer wieder von Russland blockiert und
das hat Auswirkungen auf die kasachische
Wirtschaft
Kasachstan sieht Wirtschaft durch
Russlands Krieg gebremst die Prognosen
für die Ölförderung wurden wegen
Schwierigkeiten bei der Nutzung einer
zentralen Pipeline gesenkt kasachstan
hat seine Wachstumsprognose für dieses
Jahr halbiert von vier auf zwei Prozent
und manche denken jetzt vielleicht okay
aber das ist ja nicht unser Problem aber
Moment mal liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer
auch Europa könnte es treffen wenn
Russland in kasachischen Ölhahn erneut
zudrehen sollte deshalb arbeiten die
Europäische Union Kasachstan allen
Alternativen um Russland zu umgehen und
wie die aussehen schauen wir uns jetzt
gleich an
[Musik]
es gibt wohl nur eine nachrichtenthema
das ich in diesem Sommer in Europa
genauso oft wiederholt hat wie die
Hitzewellen Putins ständige Drohung
Europa die Energie abzudrehen der Winter
naht und der Kreml nutzt Gas und Öl um
die EU dazu zu bringen ihre
Unterstützung für selenski doch noch
irgendwie zu überdenken und Kasachstan
ist diesem Spiel ebenfalls ausgeliefert
immer wieder verhindert Russland das
kasachisches Öl auf dem Weg zum
Exportmarkt Europa das Schwarze Meer
erreicht aus diesem Grund haben im Juli
Gespräche auf höchster Ebene zwischen
Astana und Brüssel begonnen denn Türkei
ist was getan werden muss der
kasachische Präsident von das neue
ölexportrouten nach dem Russland eine
schlüsselpipeline gestoppt hatte Türkei
strebt den Bau einer Pipeline quer durch
das Kaspische Meer an und Kasachstan ist
nicht das einzige Land in der Region das
am Bau einer Pipeline interessiert ist
um die eigenen Energie Ressourcen in
Richtung Europa zu exportieren auch Turk
will mit seinem Gas ins Geschäft kommen
die Zukunft bei der Projekte hängt von
Aserbaidschan auf der anderen Seite des
Kaspischen Meeres ab aber zu diesem
Thema möchte ich heute nicht zu tief in
die Details einsteigen die werden Thema
eines separaten Videos werden
schließlich ist der Konflikt zwischen
Aserbaidschan und Armenien wieder frisch
ausgebrochen und das militärische stark
geschwächte Russland kann sein
Verbündeten Armenien wohl nicht mehr
schützen aber wie gesagt die
Konsequenzen des kommenden
Zusammenbruchs der russischen
Einflusssphäre werden uns noch in
einigen zukünftigen Videos beschäftigen
falls ihr diese also nicht verpassen
wollt solltet ihr jetzt unseren Kanal
abonnieren und bitte auch das Glöckchen
aktivieren sonst lässt der Youtube
Algorithmus das Abo sowieso mehr oder
weniger unter den Tisch fallen ich danke
euch aber zurück ans Kaspische Meer in
einem früheren Video haben wir euch über
das turkmenische Gas bereits berichtet
welches die Energie sorgen Europas
merklich lindern könnte wenn es eine
Pipeline dafür über das Kaspische mehr
nach Aserbaidschan gebe von wo aus ist
bereits Gaspipelines nach Europa gibt
über Georgien und die Türkei also ohne
von Russland Wohlwollen abhängig zu sein
genau wie drückt ministan hat jedoch
auch Kasachstan das Problem dass eine
transkaspische Pipeline in diesem Fall
eine Öl nicht über Nacht gebaut werden
kann Türkei will jedoch sofortige
Lösungen und sie da vorerst haben die
Kasachen eine Formel gefunden die für
einen Weile funktionieren könnte
exklusiv Kasachstan will Öl über
aserbaidschanische Plan liefern um
Russland zu umgehen seit September setzt
Kasachstan eine Flotte von kleinen
Tankschiffen ein um sein schwarzes Gold
über das Kasper nach Baku zu
transportieren dort wird es in die BTC
Pipeline eingespeist die Baku und die
georgische Hauptstadt Tiflis und jayhan
eine türkische Stadt an der
Mittelmeerküste miteinander verbindet
die Idee ist diese Route im Jahr 2023
durch eine weitere Pipeline von
Aserbaidschan nach subsa einem
georgischen Hafen am Schwarzen Meer zu
ergänzen aber ist das dann eine
endgültige Lösung nun nein ganz und gar
nicht
denn das alles ist vollkommen
unzureichend schätzungen zufolge könnte
Kasachstan über diese roten etwa 100.000
Barrel Öl pro Tag liefern also gerade
mal 8% von dem was ist derzeit über
Russland schickt diese Zahl könnte noch
steigen wenn man eine weitere Option
hinzurechnen die in Kasachstan erhoben
wird Öl auf dem Landweg per Bahn nach
Batumi einem weiteren georgischen Hafen
am Schwarzen Meer zu transportieren aber
auch diese Route würde über russisches
Gebiet führen wäre also verletzlich
bisher handelt es sich also eher um
Flickschusterei um sicherzustellen dass
kaspisches Öl weiterhin nach Europa
gelangt wenigstens tröpfchenweise all
dies könnte jedoch der Anfang von etwas
viel Wichtigerem sein ein Zeichen dafür
dass Kasachstan nicht länger von
Russland abhängig sein will und das wäre
eine sehr bedeutsame Veränderung in
Zentralasien in der Zwischenzeit
verschwendet Türkei jetzt nämlich keine
Zeit
Kasachstans Regierungschef strickt
vorgezogene Neuwahlen und eine
Verkürzung der Amtszeit des Präsidenten
an sicherlich werden die nächsten Wahl
in Kasachstan wieder das gleiche
gleichgeschaltete Spiel sein wie schon
früher eigentlich sollten sie erst 2024
stattfinden aber Türkei will sie auf
diesen Herbst vorverlegen davor möchte
er noch dass das kasachische Parlament
eine sehr wichtige Änderung beschließt
die Begrenzung der Amtszeit des
Präsidenten auf eine einzige
siebenjährige Amtszeit Türkei jetzt ist
69 Jahre alt und kann nicht darauf
hoffen eine ganze
Ära in Kasachstan zu prägen aber in den
nächsten sieben Jahren hätte er dennoch
Gelegenheit Kasachstan stärker um zu
krempeln als vor ihm in drei Jahrzehnten
Nazar bayhev das kann dann auch
weitreichende Konsequenzen für Europa
haben je nachdem ob das Land sich
unabhängig entfalten kann und sich dabei
vielleicht Europa ernährt ob es wieder
in den Ort mit Russlands rutscht den
Einfluss des noch viel mächtigeren
Nachbarin China Gerät oder sich
vielleicht enger mit der ebenfalls in
dieser Himmelsrichtung ambitionierten
Regionalmarkt Türkei schließlich sind
die Kasachen die fast alle
zentralasiaten ein deutschsprachiges
Volk ihr seht kasachstan ist viel mehr
als nur Borat es ist möglicherweise die
bedeutendste aufstrebende Energie groß
macht die das nach der Isolation
Russlands entstandene Vakuum füllen kann
schließlich ist das zentralasiatische
Land der weltweit größte und wichtigste
Produzent eines anderen sehr bedeutenden
Energie Rohstoffs Uran wie Kernenergie
erlebt rund um den Erdball eine
fulminante Renaissance und Kasachstan
spielt hierbei eine Schlüsselrolle der
Staatskonzern casator tom ist mit einem
Weltmarktanteil von 40%
unangefochtener Weltmarktführer und das
mit Abstand als Nummer zwei folgt
Australien mit 13% und das oft
fälschlicherweise für eine große Uran
macht gehalten Russland kommt mit nur 6%
erst auf Platz 7 noch hinter Niger für
Europa das vor einer kolossalen Aufgabe
der energetischen Diversifikation steht
könnte es durchaus eine vitale Frage
darstellen in Kasachstan endlich
geostrategische Tatsachen zu schaffen
vor allem um China zuvorzukommen
Präsident Shisha Ping startete nämlich
noch kurz vor dem Treffen der Shanghai
Corporation Organisation in Tasche kennt
eine separaten Staatsbesuch in Astana ab
seine Kernbotschaft die vor allem ein
Wink mit dem Zaunpfahl an Moskau war ein
klares Bekenntnis zur reinigungslosen
Garantie der territorialen Integrität
und Souveränität Kasachstans Peking weil
damit also zu einer wichtigen
Schutzmacht der Kasachen vor der
russischen Bedrohung werden und sich
damit eine Vorzugsstellung in den
wirtschaftlichen und diplomatischen
Beziehungen zu seinem Nachbarland
sichern schließlich handelt es sich um
einen der wichtigsten wenn nicht da den
wichtigsten Knotenpunkt seiner neuen
Seitenstraßen Strategie aber das ist
schon wieder ein Thema für ein eigenes
Video visualpolitik wird die politischen
Entwicklungen in zentrale Asien
jedenfalls genau im Auge behalten aber
zunächst einmal geben wir den Ball
weiter an euch mit der Frage wird es
Kasachstan gelingen seine Abhängigkeit
von Russland zu verringern oder werden
wir eine direkte Konfrontation zwischen
Putin und Türkei erleben wie immer sind
wir auf eure angeregte Diskussion zu
diesem kontroversen Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch das dabei gelernt habt falls das
mit meinen Freunden und vergessliches
Abo mit Glöckchen und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen uns auf jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den PayPal Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]